vous pour vous jean luc mélenchon c'est
le seul candidat qui aujourd'hui vous
avez dit propose des solutions bien sûr
pour moi je trouve que enfin depuis le
début de cette campagne d'élection
présidentielle j'ai essayé d'être
attentif à chacun de leur discours donc
bien sûr j'entends parler d'économie
j'entends pour certains acquis
importants la santé
l'écologie aussi plein de sujets mais je
trouve qu'on met pas assez en lumière le
sujet des violences policières qui est
pour moi aujourd'hui un fléau qui
existent qu'il faut reconnaître et aussi
pourquoi aujourd'hui j'ai souhaité venir
ici pour en parler avec monsieur jean
luc mélenchon parce que il m'a touché
dans certaines de ses propositions qu'il
a faites face à à ce sujet
parce que moi aussi j'ai réfléchi
pendant deux ans les joues dans un
couple de cinéma est parti il ya deux
ans exactement mon père cédric joue via
je le rappelle
un père de famille qui est mort le 3
janvier 2020 tu es à pendant un contrôle
routier sain et
et qui excusez moi
et que durant six contrôles routiers il
ya eu des techniques qu'ils ont été
utilisés meurtrière depuis le début
notre affaire on les dénonce
où s'adresser aussi à emmanuel macron
qui nous a jamais répondu un monsieur à
qui nous a carrément ignoré et à
monsieur d'hermann à notre ministre de
l'intérieur qui nous a carrément enfin
qui a été insultant auprès de nos
programmes qui vous aurez presque au
moment où on a parlé
[Musique]
de deux mètres de suspendre ces quatre
policiers il a dit qu'il ne le ferait
pas donc on a l'impression qu'il les
protège actuellement alors que tous les
éléments dans notre dossier prouve que
aujourd'hui c'est des individus
dangereux
qu'ils ont utilisés qu'ils ont qui sont
acharnés son père et qui l'ont tué et en
plus de ça lorsque notre mini de
l'intérieur a parlé des violences
policières c'était pour dire que quand
elle entend violences policières il
étouffe et j'aimerais rappeler que ou
père cédric joue via pendant sa pendant
qu'il était en train de vivre sa mise à
mort ou qui quatre policiers est en
train de s'acharner et
le privé de deux de respirer je suis
crier cette fois j'ai tout et notre
ministre de l'intérieur est au courant
de ces paroles que mon père a à
prononcer et criaient de détresse et
d'agonie à ce moment là donc du coup
actuellement en tant que citoyenne bas
en tant qu'humain et en tant que fils de
victimes je suis déçu actuellement par
mon gouvernement je suis aussi déçu
mon gouvernement parce que à cause de
leurs erreurs et leur ignorance il ya
des choses qui se produisent qui sont
produites et eu des drames et si on
empêche pas tout ça et si on apporterait
des mesures et des solutions et bas ils
vont se reproduire et on pourra qu
pleurer aujourd'hui moi je veux je veux
que on n'empêche ça et je veux aussi
qu'on porte des solutions pour
comprendre la police comprendre la
population et monsieur mélenchon
aujourd'hui quand je l'entends dans ses
discours j'ai l'impression que
il entend la population il entend ce ses
cris de détresse et qu'il a envie
d'apporter des solutions et moi quand
j'ai réfléchi à certaines solutions qui
sont en accord avec monsieur mélenchon
s'est par exemple pas
quelque chose de tout simple la police
de proximité
je pense qu'avant de les armer encore
plus faudrait les écouter bien sûr il
faudrait qu'il se réconcilie avec la
population qu'ils amènent un dialogue
avec les jeunes
faudrait que finalement 106 libre
sensibilise plus les jeunes c'est à dire
ça c'est des propositions que je permet
de faire qui pour moi sont intelligentes
aujourd'hui si nécessaire aujourd'hui
parce qu'on a un grand un très grand
tournant dans notre monde dans notre
pays et il faut vraiment valoriser la
bienveillance auprès de nos deux peuples
et m haies et rassurer aussi les
victimes parce que voilà pendant deux
ans moi j'ai parlé avec des avocats des
policiers des victimes le peuple des
professeurs et on a tous été d'accord
pour dire que en ce moment on se sent
délaissée et il faut rapprocher et
réconciliée moi j'aimerais aujourd'hui
porter un message d'espoir parce que
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'espérer on a
besoin de croire on a besoin d'être
soudés avoir un moment avant vraiment un
esprit de solidarité et c'est pour ça
que je voulais parler avec vous monsieur
mélenchon
alors gens là à propos des solutions et
que j'aimerai en discuter parce que j'en
ai plaisir on discutait avec sofia les a
priori
jean-luc sofia qui a vécu un drame que
vous connaissez
et c'est vrai qu'il faut faire
maintenant est elle les six vraiment de
trouver des solutions je crois que sofia
nous aviez quelque chose elle n'est pas
anti police bien au contraire elle veut
essayer de trouver des solutions pour
que voilà la police et la population
puisse vraiment mieux vivre ensemble je
pourrais ajouter d'ailleurs quelque
chose à ce propos pour dire enfin pour
bien insister que je suis vraiment pas
un match police parce que j'ai pu cerner
aussi la souffrance bien sûr dans cette
institution et aussi j'ai remarqué
finalement tous dans notre société on
devrait privilégier voilà l'institution
policière
la santé l'éducation
pour moi c'est vraiment des secteurs qui
doit vraiment être plus valorisées et on
vous laisse la parole jean luc
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on en discute non
mais a les idées vos propositions si on
a les mêmes je le dirai voilà pas tout
simplement ben voilà la police de
proximité aux six ans valoriser plus
dans l'éducation le métier de la police
expliqué plus aux jeunes en quoi ce qui
consiste que ceux qui sont pas nous
ennemis bien sûr parce que voilà il faut
pas il faut dialoguer avec les deux pour
moi je trouve pas que c'est nos ennemis
mais je trouve que finalement la police
a fait une erreur ces derniers enfants
pendant plusieurs années c'est qu'elle a
été trop solidaire avec le corps
policier mais c'est pas un indigné de
ces gens qui ont sali aujourd'hui une
forme de la police antilles en en tuant
en étant raciste en faisant beaucoup
trop de contrôles au faciès pour moi
voilà cette question à la important de
la soulever pourquoi autant de contrôles
pourquoi quand dans un quartier
populaire où il ya des gens qui sont en
souffrance ou peut-être bien sûr qu'il
ya de la criminalité mais je pense
qu'aussi aussi sans détresse et qu'au
lieu de plus de t'être réprimant avec
eux et de de s'acharner avec des
contrôles pas plus les écouter plus
parler avec eux tous parlent avec ces
jeunes donc voilà il ya plein de choses
qui sont qui sont importantes a souligné
c'est ce sujet mérite de la lumière mais
dans les deux camps enfin dans tous les
camps parce que finalement on est avant
tout des humains on est des citoyens et
aujourd'hui on paye les hors de notre
gouvernement qui a fait que deux voiles
à se répéter au fur et à mesure parce
qu'ils n'ont pas pris les bonnes
décisions et ils ont voulu ignorer que
dans la police et il y avait des
personnes qu'ils étaient tout simplement
s'ils sont possibles si rare aujourd'hui
quand je discute avec les policiers on
remarque qu'ils sont mal formés en vue
d'avoir un dans un instant on va voir là
je sais pas si vous êtes d'accord il sut
mélenchon avec moi mais là faut la
méthode de formation elle est mauvaise
elle est scandaleuse
aussi il devrait avoir plus de suivi
avec des psychologues avec des
sociologues aujourd'hui on la
disposition beaucoup de professions qui
pourrait nous amener à nous entendre
informer et aussi bas à vivre ensemble
et c'est pour ça que je suis ici
aujourd'hui est ce que vous il ya
quelque chose mais si mélenchon c'est la
première fois qu'on entend pas jean-luc
mélenchon pour nous aussi
[Applaudissements]
déjà très bon mais ça m'a fait vraiment
ça me tient vraiment à coeur parce que
c'est une femme son père a été assassiné
sofia donc c'est pas monsieur mélenchon
c'était pour une fois son père a été
assassiné était on le sait on l'a payé
j'ai tous assuré ses hommes se sont
acharnés sur
huit corps en soit ils ont été couverts
par les organisations de policière
d'un bout à l'autre vous avez suivi la
sphère jean luc mélenchon parce que
c'est vrai que c'est une affaire à du
calme on a vu le roumain ne nous aide
pas de taille à m'intimider vous n'êtes
pas de taille à m'intimider ben s'il n'y
est pas il va arriver dans un instant
yannick l'endurance accord major
dunnebacke dans le 93 s'il vous plaît
moi je sais une chose non mais je le
père de cette jeune femme a été
assassinée et vous l'entendez avec un
calme absolu une enquête jean luc
mélenchon donc voila mais juste le voilà
en tête après c'est bien sûr il était
mort à cause de leur bien sûr c'est la
reprise j'ai bien
suivi pourquoi pourquoi vous faites sans
appel pressant parce que quand même
c'est pourquoi c'est pour vous mais je
me débrouille tout seul vous voulez bien
voilà je me débrouille tout seul
d'accord ou non mais je le dis oui mais
vous me le dites mais je me débrouille
tout seul vous pouvez c'est pour cet
homme a été assassiné
il a dit à cette reprise qui l'étouffé
repris sa défense a prétendu que le
bruit de la rue empêcher qu'on l'entende
depuis incident m'a montré que ce n'est
pas vrai cet homme a été assassiné et 7
sam vient qui est si jeune
totalement maîtrisé même nous dire moi
je suis pour qu'on s'entende qu'on se
comprenne qu'on en sorte c'est mon point
de vue je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cette forme de police et si je dois
admettre le président de ce pays je
réformerai tout de la cave au grenier et
ceux qui se sont rendus coupables
d'actes criminels
c'est certain le troc ou membres de la
police nationale parce qu'ils en sont
indignes voilà ce que j'ai à dire alors
que peut-on suis arrivé dans un instant
layani parce que là on est rouge mais
vous faites quoi vraiment donner la
parole à tous parce qu'il a donné et
j'ai vu à temps c'est à moi de
mécanique de 2,2 je peux oui ou non dire
ce que moi je ferai bien sûr ben vous
allez dire devant yannick puisqu'il est
leur nom elle c'est elle qui m'a posé la
question non mais c'est vrai elle m'a
dit la formation vous trouvez ça bien ou
pas je répond comme elle non je ne suis
pas d'accord pour qu'on ait diminué la
formation des policiers il faisait avant
deux ans ils font plus que six mois
c'est une onde deuxièmement j'ai
interdire l usage du placage ventrale
j'interdirais l'étranglement parce que
ce sont des méthodes qui sont interdites
j'interdirais le flash-ball
j'interdirais les grenades de
désencerclement la police républicaine
ne tire pas sur les gens la police
républicaine elle est aimée du public
qui elle doit se rendre respectable pour
pouvoir être respecté et cette femme a
raison de dire que notre travail
maintenant ça n'est pas de réconcilier
deux camps la police est au service de
la population du peuple souverain qui ne
lui dois rien du tout